bernard pivot vous perdez d'un nouveau
plus célèbres invités robert sabatier
des écrivains de la famille et pour les
familles
oui ces jeux c'est vrai que d'abord ce
qu'un homme qui adorait les mots et
d'égout rappelait que livre de lui
l'abécédaire c'était le seul livre
autobiographique qu'il a vraiment laissé
et si je voulais a collé un moazzam begg
bazin s'est effectivement savatier
raison c'est le mot famille d'abord
parce qu'il a raconté beaucoup
d'histoires famille on disait évidemment
vipère au poing
l'histoire de sa mère folcoche vous
savez quand il est entré à l'académie
goncourt folcoche mais ça la vraie mère
d'hervé bazin a dit ah il a fini par
réussir ce raté c'est un mot absolument
terrible et puis donc et puis il a parlé
beaucoup une madame ex le matrimoine le
la mort du petit cheval le bureau des
mariages c'est alors il puisait soit
dans ces histoires familiales hui soit
dans les familles des autres et puis
famille parce que il sait je crois qu'il
a dû se marier quatre fois et le jour de
ses 81 ans il y avait son dernier fils
qui devais avoir 7 ou 8 ans et qui
aurait pu être le petit fils de ses
premiers enfants hervé bazin donc c'est
avec alors non il a d'abord commencé par
dénoncer la famille qu'après il a été un
homme qui a adoré la famille qui a
célébré la famille et puis la famille
parce que il ya beaucoup de français et
qui nous regarde là et qui ont
évidemment souvent chez des personnes
âgées qui ont tous les romans de base 1
depuis le 1er jusqu'au dernier il
s'était un auteur absolument adoré des
familles vous disent ils vous disent et
alors qu'il ya des millions
d'exemplaires c'est qu'il a eu le prix
lénine en renommée internationale et le
prix les milieux à 7 parce que il est
c'était un best-seller extraordinaire
n'était pas du tout communiste non non
pas du tout non absolument pas et puis
l'autre famille ben saïd en dont il a
été depuis 38 ans le président le
patriarche le parrain c'était l'académie
goncourt bien sûr alors dernière chose
bernard pivot de son vivant hervé bazin
a prononcé sa propre épitaphe
et voilà il avait il avait proposé ce si
hervé bazin né en 1911 néant est né à nt
1996 alors est-ce que c'était un jeu de
mots ou est ce qu'il le pensait vraiment
merci